finally last night almost exactly a year
after we had our first development
meeting about the film what is a woman
premiered on the daily wire it was by
all measures and enormous success we
gained more subscribers in a day than at
any other point
in the company's history we had more
people watching the film than we've ever
had watching any piece of content all at
once uh the movie is we could say for
sure now a massive hit but
we knew going in
that we were wading into treacherous
waters gender ideology lies deep down
at the core of our society's dominant
religion which is leftism
it's expected that if you go near it you
know if you dare approach the altar that
you do you do so with reverence avert
your eyes keep your head bowed bow
before the sacred cow repeat the
necessary incantations and then and then
shuffle along move on that's how you're
supposed to approach gender ideology to
do anything else to approach this thing
with anything less than
dogmatic veneration is an act of
unspeakable sacrilege
and to actually question it to look into
its face and challenge it directly is
the ultimate blasphemy
and we all know what religious zealots
do to blasphemer blasphemers that's what
we were expecting here so it was in that
sense
no surprise that the daily wire came
under a sustained and seemingly quite
sophisticated cyber attack during the
premiere of the film as the film started
to play we were flooded with messages
and emails from members who were trying
to watch but were running into all sorts
of strange glitches
and even in spite of this just on the
strength of people who could make it
through and access the film it was still
a record-breaking premiere for the daily
wire but it became clear pretty quickly
that something malicious was happening
and soon our tech team was able to
verify and um from here i'll read from
the daily wire article about it because
i think the news team will do a better
job of explaining the specifics about
this than i will so reading from the
daily wire article it says the daily
wire came under a sustained um ddos
attack during the world premiere of what
is a woman that was intended to disrupt
people being able to access the highly
anticipated film quote we've confirmed
that daley wire experienced a
significant sustained ddos attack
tonight meant to disrupt the world
premiere of what is a woman jeremy
boring said in a statement a million
requests per minute at the peak flooded
our system and created challenges for
many viewers the attack began shortly
after the start of the live stream of
daily wires backstage program which
preceded the premiere and featured daily
wire hosts discussing the making and
meaning of the film many users encounter
difficulty accessing the live stream due
to the malicious event a distributed
denial of service ddos attack is a type
of coordinated malicious campaign that
seeks to shut down a targeted server by
flooding the server with extreme levels
of traffic coming from bots
the extremely high levels of traffic use
up the server's resources and prevent
real users from being able to access it
so
in summary
um they don't want you to see this film
i mean they really
don't want you to see it
meanwhile on twitter there were trans
activists um tweeting out their
fantasies about bashing me in the head
with a baseball bat there were other
activists organizing a campaign to try
and take over the what is a woman
hashtag a hashtag which by the way has
been suppressed by twitter because every
time it starts to trend twitter just
pushes it back down but the activists
tried to hijack it with various lies and
insults and defamation directed at me
they were like openly organizing with
each other talking amongst each other
you know on the social media platform
about what sorts of slanderous things
they could make up about me and they
were kind of because this is what you
can do if you're trans activists on
twitter you could be out in the open hey
we're gonna we're gonna make up some uh
we're gonna defame this guy what should
we say about him and you can have that
conversation and there's not gonna be
any consequence
now as i said this is just the beginning
they hate this film
they're terrified of it
and uh they hate me for making it now
granted they already hated me before
this but now even more so
and why i mean anybody who saw the film
and if you haven't yet you can go to the
daily wire right now become a member and
watch it on demand it is available to be
to be seen right now
but anyone who uh saw it knows that i
wasn't lying or joking when i said that
all i do for the majority of the film is
ask simple questions i'm not going
around screaming at people
there's a little bit of that mostly at
the women's march because that was just
fun but for the vast majority of the
runtime i'm sitting down with people
and asking them the simplest and
seemingly easiest questions imaginable
questions that supposed experts in these
fields ought to be able to answer with
ease
that's all i'm doing
and that's exactly why they don't want
you to see this it's the emperor has no
close fable brought to life
gender ideology
lies at the core of leftism
but the core of gender ideology the core
of the core
is empty it's hollow there's nothing
there it's all smoke and mirrors in
sleight of hand tricks
everything they say is nonsense
it has no logical or intellectual
anchor it's this flimsy frail little
thing easily swatted away
it can be crushed under the weight of a
question
any question at all in fact
that's one of the fascinating things
about making this film is that you know
i knew that what is a woman is going to
be a stumper of a question for these
people but what i didn't quite realize
is that um leading up to that question
really any question at all
is a stumper doesn't any question if
it's asked with actual uh sincere
skepticism
is is unanswerable to them
and this is what makes them so angry
i experienced this while filming the
documentary in fact there were two
emotions that came through in nearly
every interaction
that we had through the course of
filming and that is fear and anger
two emotions that often come packaged
together right and the fear mostly came
from the average people on the street
who you could tell
most of them knew the truth they
understood how ridiculous the claims
made by trans activists are but uh they
were petrified to talk about it
especially on camera
because they've been coerced and cajoled
and threatened into silence
the anger meanwhile and a good bit of
fear too
came from the alleged experts the
academics doctors politicians
who stormed out of interviews lashed out
made accusations became extremely
defensive
the moment they realized that i was
going to ask real questions
not even hard questions just
questions actual questions
they weren't expecting that because in
their minds
the relationship between a learned
authority such as themselves
and an uneducated flannel-clad bumpkin
such as myself is supposed to be one of
cult leader and disciple
they're supposed to make declarations
and proclamations and i'm supposed to
sit in slack-jawed awe
nodding my head submissively
accepting without question everything
that comes out of their mouths
the opponents
as opposed to the proponents
are incredibly open and eager to answer
questions eager to have the conversation
on one hand you have
uh people curling up into the fetal
position because i asked the question on
the other
you have scott nugent who's the woman
who transitioned to a man or
transitioned to appear like a man as she
puts it herself in the film i want you
to listen to uh nugent talk about
the dark reality of uh gender transition
for the first time in history
a marginalized group has a huge dollar
sign on the top of their head
we have five
children's hospitals in the united
states
promoting that
what that's a phalloplasty that's a
bottom surgery
we have five children's hospitals in the
united states
telling girls
that they can be boys
at seventy thousand dollars a pop in a
surgery that has a sixty seven percent
complication rate that will kill me from
infection that i can't sue on
butchering a generation of children
because nobody's willing to talk about
anything
i have three kids
[Music]
at the age that they're doing this to
kids
i'm not transphobic
i love my kids and i love other people's
kids and you should too
this is wrong
on so many levels
so from uh from nugent
who is the true hero of the film in my
opinion we get total
openness and uh honesty raw
gut-wrenching honesty
from the other side we get defensiveness
lies accusations
one side wants us all to talk about this
right like let's talk about this
the other side wants to talk wants to be
the one talking while we shut up
and they'll do anything they can to shut
us up
but they will fail they already have
because this film isn't going anywhere
it's on the site right now available to
be seen by anybody with a membership and
if you don't have one
i ask you to go sign up nobody else is
making films like this this is the kind
of content we can make and will make
we're willing to deal with whatever the
consequences are
they're coming after the daily wire
they're coming after me personally
and i expect them on the ladder thing to
to ramp that up
the good news is that it won't work it
can't work if we have
your support if we all kind of stick
together there's nothing they can do but
scream and cry if they try to escalate
beyond that if they try to you know
let's say make good on those baseball
bat to the head promises then we have
other ways of dealing with that and it
will be dealt with i assure you but
outside of physical violence any other
attack fails
if we stay unified
because that's if if you if if there's a
united front
and they're gonna scream and cry and we
just say we don't care that you're
screaming and crying
this is a conversation we're gonna have
whether you like it or not if we say
that then
that's it they lose
so go to what is woman.com and get your
membership um our team is uh you know
working around the clock to fight this
cyber attack as
far as i know basically gotten it
completely under control
if you do run into any glitches just be
patient stick with us and remember that
um this this fight the fight against the
the sickening
toxic madness of gender ideology
it it can be won we can beat them
we can win i really believe that and uh
and we have to we have to win
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends